hello and welcome to PlayStation Grenade
Christmas time
what's Christmastime like for you
terrible music overeating and avoiding
your family by any means necessary
yeah me too this time of year also
brings in Christmas events and video
games most of which are happy jovial
jolly Affairs but some of them are
downright weird and others are so
irrational they make for an alternative
to Christmas so if you love Christmas or
if you are thinking Fox and then here
are five crazy Christmas stories only
found in video games let's start with
Borland
- and the retelling of a Christmas
classic in the third headhunted DLC pack
arms dealer Marcus ends our vault hunter
- the holiday town of ginger t'en
complete with gingerbread houses and
murderous snowmen in this alternative
universe Christmas has been replaced by
mercenary day in honor of Marcus saving
the town
although Marcus remembers things a
little differently still with townsfolk
around you think I'm their safety just
cuz I was gonna hire you to kill them
but I changed my mind
after walking through a mysterious
wardrobe as if we were venturing into
Narnia
our heroes fight through bandits and the
aforementioned snowmen on the way
opening many a Christmas present
this wouldn't be a Christmas story
without Tiny Tim but due to copyright
issues Borderlands opts for small Tim or
to give him his full name smaller than
average Timothy he must have had a tough
childhood oh and what did Tim get for
Christmas my birth buried a gift last
year was Brigid lookie guy Tim tells us
about a boss snow man who needs a little
warming up so off we trot to unleash mr.
frosty of course he's the biggest
snowman in history and he's more than
prepared to Wreckers with Christmas
themed attacks one of the greatest
things about this boss fight is his name
tinder snowflake may sound like an
online dating organization but fighting
him consecutively will add words to his
title in my last fight with tinder his
name read his abominable nurse sir
tinder snowflake Esquire once the
adventure is over we have saved ginger
ttan and are rewarded with Christmas
gifts galore and a train stuffed with
loot and that was the story of how
Marcus saves mercenary day with a tiny
bit of help from oz of course next in
our Christmas video game storytelling is
hitman I know what you're thinking how
the hell can a game about undetected
murder be related to Christmas
well it's through the free holiday
hoarders DLC the decor here in France
has been updated and is now brimming
with Christmas cheer our mission is to
eliminate two professional thieves
currently ransacking the mansion they
are from a famous Christmas film you've
probably seen before and if you haven't
I highly recommend it here's your first
clue the two thieves are named Harry and
Marv and look quite distinctive figured
out the film yet let's follow one of
them around he's a bit of an idiot who
leaves sinks overflowing he even calls
the duo the Wet Bandits got it yet it is
indeed home alone what a great film it's
pretty much on every single day around
Christmas the holiday hoarders dlc also
allows agent 47 to unlock the Santa
costume by finding all the artifacts
before Harry and Marv grab them this
lets us see what Santa does in
his time off globe-trotting to warm
destinations and killing everyone in
sight now that's the Santa we know and
love let's go back to 1991 and the
phenomenon that was James pond robo Cod
okay so if you're new to this it will
seem like the strangest videogame
concepts you can imagine he's a stretchy
fish thing with armor like Robocop and
the skills of James Bond the 90s were a
very strange time for video games but
just check out this little stretchy buck
turd in James Bond second outing row
ball cod is tracking down his arch enemy
dr. Maeby who has taken over the North
Pole and is using Santa's workshop as a
home base that's where we roll in and
use our unique skills to rescue Santa's
little helpers which are either elves or
penguins depending on which version of
the game you play doctor maybe changes
into various Christmas themed villains
throughout the game with his final fight
taking the shape of yet another
overspiced Nona once defeated he makes a
last-ditch run for it but the real Santa
is on hand to drop his manly stack to
drop his huge load I have no idea how to
make that sound less perverted the only
way we can celebrate this victory is
through random jumping animations and
the greatest ending in videogame history
well done
the world is safe really that's it talk
about a disappointing ending thanks
robot : the next one is a bit of a
downer but I think it deserves a mention
the story of the division it wasn't all
about looting and cover shooting and
those futuristic orange watches the
division has a precautionary Christmas
tale to tell us starting on Black Friday
a smallpox pandemic hits New York via
banknotes which are passed around like
they are going out of fashion on the
biggest spending day of the year by the
time Christmas rolls in the population
is absolutely decimated and Central Park
is a graveyard it's so surreal walking
through the snowy streets seeing the
Christmas trees and even the coca-cola
truck is here but it's been left for
dead it's chilling and that's not a pun
it's a crazy Christmas indeed but damn
this got depressing fast let's move on
let's do something a bit more uplift
let's visit the saints row guys this
ragtag anti-hero group all loved
Christmas except for the boss I just
think there's more important things to
think about than some Bulls holiday
looks like someone never got on the nice
list
suddenly cyborg Sean D travels back in
time from a future where tight clothes
are all the fashion and breasticles are
made to be crushed into oblivion
over to you Sean D come midnight
Christmas Day Santa Claus has come into
town and unless we stop him he is going
to put the universe on the naughty list
and trust me you don't want to be on the
naughty list sorry I asked
so over a few decades santa's mind has
been deranged and now he's been replaced
by Claus the warlock this version of
Claus is using Santa's workshop to send
children guns and bombs instead of dolls
and toy cars and our job is to stop him
first by wearing terrible Christmas
jumpers second by killing countless
gingerbread men and Nutcracker soldiers
and then delivering presents to the good
kids and good old coal to those little
sheets nobody loves the final fight
pizzas against Claus culminating in this
I just want to be clear you can't murder
your way onto the nice list Sarah I who
never believed in me but despite that
you spread cheer to the people of
Steelport you save the holiday and for
that I thank you all this needs now is a
Christmas montage I spoke too soon
so there we have it five crazy
Christmases we've lived through thanks
to video games did I miss any from the
list please let me know in the comments
and what games do you tend to play
around Christmastime
I'm Adam from Playstation grenades and
to all that celebrate it have a great
Christmas it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time